[موسيقى]
تمسكوا بذراع والدها بانتظار ان تمسك
بزمام الامور في البلاد الطفله المحبوبه
لزعيم كوريا
خليفه
وفق صحيفه التايمز البريطانيه
وبدا هذا الامر واضحا بعد ان كشف كم
النقابه عن ابنته البالغه من العمر عشره
اعوامه مخالفا بذلك تقاليد الحكم المتعارف
عليها ليربط الاخلاص له بالولاء لطفلته
لانه ينوي تعزيز فكره انها هي من ستخلفه
تقول صحيفه البريطانيه
ابعد من ذلك ظهور طفلتي كم يهدف الى نزع
فتيل التنافس الحاد بين الامراتين الاكثر
اهميه في حياته وهما زوجته وشقيقته
الطموحه كم يوم جونغ لانه في حاله رحيل كم
من دون ان يكون لديه خليفه معروفه فان ذلك
سيؤدي الى فراغ في السلطه وبالتالي فان
الصراع سيحتدم بين الارمله والشقيقه
كم قويه جدا وعدوانيه وطموحه وزوجته كم
غير راضيه عنها ولاجل ذلك اخرج الزعيم
الكري ابنته الى العالم لتفادي الصراع
وتدهور البلاد في حال وفاته ولكن حتى
الساعه تعد شقيقه زعيم البالغه من العمر
35 عاما اقوى امراه في البلاد لانها
الاقرب اليه من مساعديه والمتحدثه باسمه
في ما يتعلق بالعلاقات مع كوريا الجنوبيه